Well listen, we're talking about this last
time was with you, the proud boys. Yeah.
Yeah. Got it off as a goof and
then became like, what the,
they won't let him in Australia
now if you've seen that. No, it's,
it's gotten insane.
Yeah.
Like Gavin is considered like
a war criminal at this point.
I know Gavin very well. He used to
be on compound media, my, my network.
Um, and that's where the whole
thing started. And space junk.
Explain how it all started
because people don't know. It's,
it's amazing when you think about it
because it makes you question everything.
Like how did, how did Nazi
Germany stock, was that a joke?
Was that like Stalin Ism than
everything? Uh, in Russia? Uh, Gavin,
how does show very outrageous?
Gavin is one of these, just a funny,
outrageous guy. His whole career has
been based on satire and parody and,
and he's very loud to provocate tool,
right? Provocateur. Absolutely. Yeah.
Loves shaking. People are
to find out where he really,
well, how he really feels.
And when he's playing games, it's very
blurry. Absolutely. So we have, uh,
we have this employee, uh,
Ben Ratner, little kid.
We actually hired him just because his
name was Ratner and we wanted to call him
rat, like in fast times a rent. Why
don't you turn on the camera? Uh,
so it was, it was great. Uh,
he rat never talked about girls.
It's like this really Jewish,
really red hair,
kind of gangly, you know, kid. And uh, he,
he liked going to Broadway shows and
things and we always questioned his
sexuality and whatnot. And Gavin
really started hitting on him going,
what are you doing? Like get laid a
kid, your age should be out there.
It just fucking plowing through
policy and a, he's like, ah, you know,
waiting for the right girl and everything.
So Gavin would continuously goof on him.
So he would always go to Broadway
plays. So Gavin started getting, uh,
music from musicals and playing it to
him. Like, Hey, look at this, you pussy,
you know, is this what you like? And
one of them was proud of your boy.
It's a Broadway, a song from a
musical, a Disney musical, I believe.
And it's sealed. Oh, proud of your boy.
It's one of those big grandiose
Broadway pieces of shit.
I can't stand that stuff,
man. I hate it. Oh, it is.
It's terrible.
So he goofed on about that and then said,
we ought to make a club
called the proud boys.
And that way you can learn how to
be a man and you know, you, you,
you'll get chicks and
tattoos and you know,
drink beer and hang out
with guys as a joke.
It was like this parody of a men's club
and so over the top that it was like,
I think part of the way to
get beaten into this gang,
this club was that you had to recite
five breakfast cereals while the other
members punched you and they would
keep punching you until you spit.
So ludicrous. So ridiculous.
Such a parity. Uh,
and slowly this fucking
thing mutated into something.
It got more members. Uh,
they started wearing, um,
what are those shirts? The, with a yellow
car piping on the collar and stuff.
It's a specific shirt that
became the uniform. Perry Ellis,
Perry Ellis shirts,
a specific black shirt with gold piping
and a on the collar and, and the,
uh, the sleeves. And that
became like the uniform.
And because it was presented as
a chauvinist stick club, like,
like girls are allowed, minorities are
allowed. It doesn't matter who you are,
but in essence it is a guy thing and
we will talk shit about girls and we're
going to drink and get laid.
And it was just a men thing.
So they started getting together at
bars, you know, in the area in Manhattan.
And how is this organized? This is
organized through his compound media show,
through the compound media show,
his own Twitter account and Facebook,
which he subsequently lost.
He's persona non grata on a social media,
but that's how it started.
And it never was supposed
to go any further than that.
Gavin himself didn't really
take it any further than that.
It's just let's get together
every so often. We have a
good time, we drink, laugh,
everything like that.
Well then this whole thing with a
politics got involved cause Antifa,
which is antifascist started, uh, uh,
coming into, uh, conservatives
that wanted to speak.
So Gavin was conservative,
is conservative.
He'd get speaking engagements
at schools, Nyu or, um,
any, any of the numerous
places around New York City.
And antifa would show up to protest
him and try to shut down the event.
So then the proud boys would go and
protect Gavin so he wouldn't get harmed
doing these speaking
engagements. Uh, and that,
so then it turned into this because
they're fighting with Antifa.
They must be the fog, the
fascists and the Nazis. Um,
and once that gets out there,
there's no pulling it back.
You could try to explain how you're not
a Nazi till you're blue in the fucking
face. It ain't going away. And
especially cause it's a good story.
The press likes it.
It's this good versus evil thing.
They present Antifa I like their protest.
They always call them.
And the protesters were beaten.
They're fucking violent. Uh,
a violent group of people that are there
to hit people they don't agree with and
silence people that want to speak.
And that's exactly what happened
with Kevin and Ann Coulter and Milo
Yiannopoulos. Uh, Ben Shapiro.
There a lot of these conservative people
can't go to these venues and speak.
They get shut down because
of a violent group of people
called ANTIFA. So proud boys
were kind of the answer to that.
So Gavin can go round and,
and actually, uh, speak.
Well when that happened,
more people came on board because
they kind of liked to beat people up.
Uh, when you have a
gang, a group of people,
and one of their missions is now to
beat up people you don't agree with
politically. When there was TV outlets,
there's tears to the membership.
Like the highest tier was you
fought for the cause, right, right.
To actually get in a fist fight.
Yeah, sure. Gavin thought it was like,
I've talked to Gavin,
I'd like Gavin.
I've had Gavin on the podcast
and the last time I had them on,
I didn't know what this whole thing was.
He was explaining the proud boys and he
was talking to me about we're going to
punch them, we're going to punch people.
Yeah. I was like, Whoa, Whoa, whoa.
I was like,
did you don't,
you can't just punch people like
they punched back and then you get,
they get mad that you punched him in and
they shoot you when you get out of your
car. Right. This escalates.
People don't just take it. Well,
it was never supposed to be an
offensive punching. Uh, when,
when I would speak to Gavin and every
example I would see it was an answer to
violence.
They,
they would have violence perpetrated
on that and probably they answered with
context and all Paul needed to say is
he's calling for violence. That's it.
And that's what they've said about
Gavin over and over again. Right.
Taking things out of context
and use it as a gamble.
The other problem being that the Antifa
people are a lot of skinny dudes and
chicks with masks on and they are
not really that adept at fighting.
It is a horrible video of this one.
Antifa guy tries to hit someone with
it looks like some kind of a stick or a
pipe and the guy catches it and
fucking blast him on the champion.
Fucking put him down. His head
bounces off the concrete unconscious.
A lot of people die. Yeah, yeah, exactly.
That's how people die in fights. Like, oh,
he killed him with his bare hands.
Yeah. You hit his fucking head on.
He hit his head on the concrete. You got
hit by the world. Literally the world.
Right, right. Back. Gravity budge it.
Gravity has punched you in the
back of the head. Yeah. Yes.
These people have this idea
that they're going to go places.
They're going to shut everybody
down and because they're in a group,
you're going to scream and yell and
hit people with bike locks and all this
stuff. All seen weird thing
is that that's from the left.
That was never from the left before. When
I was a kid, I grew up, um, when I was a,
from age seven 11,
during the Vietnam War,
I lived in San Francisco and
I was around the real hippies.
And I remember being a little
kid and I remember that. I mean,
if times there were flower children,
I mean they were, they, right,
the hippies and the lefties were not,
were love and peace and no violence
and everyone was doing acid, right.
Hey, and now they're all on Adderall
and it hitting people with bike locks.
It was, yeah, it's a different thing.
There was a time where the liberals,
the hippies, the, you know, they,
they were the ones that when there would
be a demonstration and the national
guard would show up, they'd be putting
flowers in the barrels of the guns,
famous pictures
of that. And then Kent state
was a bunch of hippies,
literally getting shot
by the National Guard,
the national guard that has
completely flipped around.
It's the weirdest thing.
And I don't know how it got distinguished.
We're proud boys became this
evil group of people and,
and Antifa is the good group of people.
Now I understand that proud boy,
uh, proud boys were infiltrated
by white nationalists,
Nazi White Supremacist,
whatever it is.
But those were constantly
being disavowed by Gavin.
Gavin never wanted any of that happening,
but is there a way,
how do you get in though?
Here's the question because this is my,
you saw my last comedy
special [inaudible].
This is my criticism of a vegans is not
that there's anything wrong with being a
Vegan, right? That when you have
a group where anybody can join,
you're going to get a certain
amount of fucking idiots, right?
If you have a million people,
for sure,
you have 100,000 fucking idiot
has no getting around that. Yeah,
so if you have a group where anybody can
join and you have a million people in
that group,
you're going to have 100,000 fucking
idiot fucking idiot and those people are
going to define your group.
The worst behavior in that group is
where people are going to call two as an
example. That's it. I think this is also
a symptom of the social media era today,
especially with Twitter,
because you can't express yourself and
explain things 140 or 280 characters,
it just takes too much time. So they can
say, oh, proud boys, racist, scumbag,
Nazi Gavin, and there are
always a racist scumbag Nazi,
and all a sudden that's the narrative
and everybody keeps pushing it.
And that's the videos of people
punching little skinny people.
Oh look at these people.
They beat up the Antifa,
these fucking assholes and
Gavin's an asshole. Yeah, that's,
that's what it comes down to.
I've seen it presented. Uh,
well you ask how it starts and how it
grows and how you become a member by
buying a fucking shirt.
That's by buying a Perry Ellis
shirt and opening a chapter two.
There are chapters worldwide. You
see it. It's like, here's the,
the proud boys Australia.
Here's the problem is England
proud boys fucking Japan.
Like it's everywhere and it never
was supposed to get to that point.
And regardless of how these people act,
it now reflects on Gavin even though he
wanted to hang out in a bar with a few
people do as public speaking without
being hassled. And that's it. And,
and I see the way the
media manipulates things.
I've been party to it myself and I've
seen Gavin presented in photos where you
look and go, holy fuck, it's
Hitler liked like they get them.
There's one picture of Gavin that I was
petrified by. He's got his arms folded,
he's got a scowl on his face, that
hair, you know the short on the side,
long on the top and he's looking like,
like he's angry. And I'm like that.
That's not the guy that him and his
wife who's American Indian by the way,
his wife is American Indian.
He's got beautiful kids that come over
my house and use the pool and we
hang out and barbecue and I'm like,
that's not that guy.
No one knows that guy from the paper.
They're getting this impression.
He's a really nice guy. He's,
he's a generous,
just a really cool guy to hang out with
and what you see them do in the media is
just crazy.
Especially when you know he didn't
invent some God Damn Nazi group.
He was just trying to have a little
outrageous fun and it ran from him.
It got away from him.
The origin of it though,
the way you're describing
that is fucking fantastic.
Isn't that nuts to crazy that
that is what presented it?
I mean that that emerged out of that we,
we,
we fuck with rat all
the time because we go,
can you believe the inspiration for the
proud boys is this little Jewish kid?
Is that guy's photo online? Oh, I'm
sure there is. Yeah. Pull it up. Rats,
rat compound media rat.
You'll probably find them of how
much does this weird you out though?
That compound media was the
source of all this is weird. Like,
and it's one of those things
that you worry about like,
like I don't want to then be tied because
I know how it works. I love Gavin,
but I don't want to be tied to the
proud boys at this point. You know,
I got my own fucking problems
through history. I don't
need any more piled on me,
but what was that thing that I'd sent
you? That here. There he is. There he is.
That's a rat. I guess that was
Halloween. You, I was wearing a suit.
That was, I was the mayor from jaws.
Oh, mayor Vaughn. I was for Halloween.
That's awesome.
That's the guy that started the proud.
He started the proud boys guy.
1938 propaganda posters. Little Cutie
isn't the Norman Rockwell painting.
That's it.
He should be there with like a,
like a guy who's handing them an
apple pie. Yeah. Yeah. And that's,
that's the face of the new Nazi movement.
I think there's a lot of
mistakes were made. Gavin's,
Gavin's made some mistakes and like his,
his whole thing of,
of not of blurring the lines
between parody and honesty's.
It's, he thinks it's fun. It's very
punk rock. He came up last time,
he's on the podcast,
which is a few years back.
He came on dressed like Michael Douglas
from falling down. He had a briefcase.
He brought the suit like the short sleeve.
She dresses like that all the time
now. Like he goes around, I just,
I just did a Skype interview
with him, uh, yesterday,
two days ago and from the
hotel room and he, uh,
he's got the pocket protector and
the pens and the glasses. Yeah.
Like falling down. He thinks it's
funny, but people need to understand,
and this is true, he is the
godfather of the hipsters. Yeah.
He'll put in godfather of
hipsters, Google. He comes up,
all of that wardrobe that
guys are wearing. They would,
they look like they're wearing old
timey suits with a skinny ties. Yeah.
That's Gavin McInnes.
Yeah.
Literally started that fashion trend
in Williamsburg. Yeah. And they,
it took off from there
that the hipster dress,
the way people would dress with those
weird mustaches and all that shit. Yeah.
That literally came out of Gavin Gavin
it, which is amazing. The motherfucker is,
he is like a,
yeah,
there's something like
magnetic about the guy.
He is what a cult leader is like.
He could just start a cult,
which in essence by accident he did
between the hipsters and then this.
He's one of those guys like,
like, Gavin, why don't you start?
Why didn't you start a cult where
you get to fuck the people's wives?
Like that kind of cult. Why?
Why do you go with what?
He also did some really good interviews
online where he would trick these
leftists into sitting down with him in
interviews and then along the way there
we're having this conversation.
It would be exposed that he didn't agree
with them at all and they were trapped
like this hardcore feminist
got trapped with them.
A couple of other people get trapped in
this room with him and they they realize
like halfway it like some of the
line of questioning and the way he's
approaching things like, oh my
God, he's an interesting guy.
He's very interesting and outside
of this progress thing of you never,
never invented that. They never did any
of that. He would be doing great. Yeah.
Although he had a problem with one of
one of his own companies that he made
after vice,
they bought them out of vice because uh,
Shane turned more liberal
and it wasn't really,
they weren't really meshing
anymore over their advice,
so they kinda just bought out. Uh, Gavin,
he got a lot of money and
decided to do his own thing.
He had an advertising
firm, I guess it was. Uh,
and then he got the boot from that
for making a trans gender comments.
Well, he was telling Damien I was
transgender people have mental health,
mental health issue. He was bringing up
all these, here's the problem. He was,
he was saying some things that are
correct. Yeah. Interspersed with, again,
yeah, already in sarcasm, but
in his mind this was like just,
this is something you can talk about
where it was in the public side,
particularly during the Caitlyn
Jenner. Yeah. Whole thing.
People had decided the transgender was
amazing. It's amazing. It's beautiful.
She's incredible. And he was saying, no,
these are people that are
mentally ill and there's an a,
there's a website and
that he was pointing to,
I think it's called transgender regrets
or something like that where they have
all these stories of all these men who
turned into women and turned back to men
again. Now they don't
have dicks, no cheese,
and they have to take testosterone
injections and they hate their life.
And there's,
uh,
some of them who did it like when they
were in their sixties and now they're in
their seventies and trying
to be a man again. And,
and that gender dysphoria was
thought to be a mental health issue.
Like Anorexia, like a lot, a lot of
other, there's, there's body dysphoria.
It'd be people have weird, um, you know,
uh, bodybuilders get it. They, they,
they never think they're big enough.
We'll have like weird perceptions of
their physical presence and their B and
some, uh, I had a
psychologist, Dr Deborah,
so who was discussing late onset
gender dysphoria in autistic girls that
autistic teenage girls,
they don't feel like they fit in and
people can convince them that they're
actually a man. Wow. And so a lot
of them start taking hormones and,
and going through transition,
massive regrets.
And then unfortunately for women,
when,
especially when you're a teenager and
you're going through puberty and you take
hormones, you literally start
developing male features.
Your face gets harder and thicker
and wider. Your shoulders get bigger,
like the whole deal. Your hands click
grows to the size of a thumb you,
so you make these irreversible
changes or unless, you know,
so you just described Jim Norton's
dream girl. Yeah. Perfect.